[Applause]
[Music]
as ethic falls she remembers she
remembers the world
before they unearthed the crystal she
remembers the glee she felt when she
built her first robot
but mostly she remembers the friends
she's made these last few days
courageous adila and her resistance
movement
octavia's sacrificed to keep the guards
distracted
lemma and her idealistic drive to cure
everyone
and hedge her creation her
responsibility
her failure her betrayer hedge who
convinced her to collect the three nodes
that she never
actually needed for ethic remembers how
to operate the world machine
if only she could get a second chance at
[Music]
it
from
[Music]
adela has been in radio contact with
octavia whom the robots captured and
imprisoned
in the same jail that held ethic ethic
explains that hedge has manipulated them
all
and will now try to break down the brad
barrier and cover the entire world
in a giant maze unless they can stop him
but she has a plan ethic herself will go
to the crystal at the center of the maze
and use its powers to stop hedge
meanwhile adela and lemma will do
whatever they can
to slow hedge down
[Music]
foreign
as epic weaves her way towards the
innermost maze
her radio picks up a transmission
octavia has freed hundreds of members of
the resistance from stasis
together they've staged a jailbreak and
overwhelmed the guards
the resistance has access to the world
machine but they don't know how to use
it
they'll need ethic for that all they
have at their disposal
are nearly limitless spools of wire
the strands are durable but prisoners
can break them deliberately
if they need to
efik reaches the entrance to the
innermost maze
and it's sealed from within
she remembers a few things from when she
flew over the maze
days earlier it centers on the crystal
there are many dead ends
but no paths that loop back on
themselves
[Music]
ethic has one opportunity to radio the
members of the resistance
a simple set of instructions before they
plunge into the labyrinth in search of
the exit
what directions can she give them so
they can quickly navigate the maze
open the door and guide ethic straight
back to the crystal
here's a hint one of the challenges here
is to find a way to indicate
where dead ends are so that the
resistance members
don't keep going down them try
simplifying the maze to something like
this
let's say you've just hit this dead end
then came back to this intersection
what could you do to show the next
person who gets here
that they don't need to explore that
path
most programming puzzles involve giving
instructions to a single actor
so that they can accomplish a goal
instead
here we have a swarm of individuals each
of whom can follow basic instructions
that's unusual in programming but not
unheard of
researchers are currently experimenting
with swarms of small robots
to do things like conduct search and
rescue missions
the prisoners aren't robots but for
ethics purposes
they'll act like them and by working
together they can achieve their goal
much more efficiently because you have a
lot of prisoners
you'll want them to cover a lot of
ground this matches up well to a maze
mapping technique
called a depth first search it's called
that
because it involves going as deeply down
a path as possible
before going back in other words if you
had a maze like this
you'd want to explore all the way down
one of these branches
before returning to this intersection
and trying another
everyone needs a clear set of
instructions for what they should do
like first tie down the loose end of
your wire
by the crystal so it leads back there if
you find the door
open it and hand your spool to ethic if
you're in a passageway
keep going until you hit a dead end or
an intersection
but what happens at either of those
places
if someone encounters a dead end they
should backtrack to the last
intersection
but they also need to mark it so no one
wastes time and goes back there
the best tool for that is the wire one
option
is to break both sections that lead down
the dead end path
and tie the spool to the wire that leads
back to the crystal
the broken wires tell everyone else who
gets to this intersection
don't go this way they'll also guarantee
the final path will lead straight to the
crystal
rather than visiting dead ends okay
so let's say someone's at an
intersection now which way should they
go
the first priority is to have everyone
cover fresh ground
to minimize doubling up so if there's no
wire down a direction
go that way if there are multiple
choices choose one at random
what if they're in a subsection like
this with three
marked dead ends the only thing to do is
to go back where they came from
we now know that this whole section is
one big dead end
so they should break and re-tie the wire
when they get to the next intersection
but let's say they get there and find
two options
where someone's exploring but no one's
hit a dead end yet
they may as well choose at random and go
help explore that path further
in case it's the right direction for the
exit
this isn't the only way to solve this
challenge but in any correct method
someone will eventually find the way out
the moment
of truth will be when ethic takes their
wire and follows it back
inward towards her goal the great thing
about this method
is that ethics path is straight and true
the maze doesn't have loops
so there's only one path from door to
crystal
and because everyone has been breaking
and re-tying their wires
ethic won't go down any dead-end paths
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
so
face to face with her creation ethic has
a choice
she can destroy hedge or set things
right
all of this destruction was her fault
not hedges
it was her oversight that instructed him
to build an infinitely large maze
his decisions were misguided but
everything he did
he did to follow his programming ethic
accesses his core
and fixes her error with a single number
the size
the maze was supposed to reach
[Music]
ethic has prevented catastrophe and
regained possession
of the world machine her work with adela
octavia and lema
has already started to help people and
heal the world's turmoil
but there's much work to be done with
the forgetting food out of their systems
the people will become themselves again
they'll regain their will to create
and progress they'll be free to break
down the walls they've built between
each other
and they may come to approach their
future with a little less greed
and a little more epic
this saga may be over but with your new
skills
new adventures await think like a coder
was ted-ed's first episodic series
bringing together artists and educators
from across the globe
if you enjoyed it please support us on
patreon
and be a part of our mission to bring
free
high quality educational resources to
the world